voilà ce qu'il recherchait c'est le laps
négation de l'ukraine le déni de
l'ukraine ce sont les mots de jean yves
le drian qui a tenu une conférence de
presse avec josette borel le chef de la
diplomatie européenne qui lui dénonce un
processus de destruction systématique
des infrastructures militaires et civils
en ukraine joseph bourrel caroline de
camaret qui évalue à un million six cent
mille le nombre de réfugiés en europe
donc de réfugiés ukrainien en europe en
douze jours de grades de guerre et à
terme il pourrait être 5 millions à
franchir les frontières européennes donc
c'est une mobilisation exceptionnelle là
que s'apprêtent à vivre les européens
oui il a noté d'ailleurs la pente
vertigineuse et la progression de ce
nombre de réfugiés exponentielle du
jamais vu depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale at il estimé josep borrell qui
d'ailleurs a parlé d'un nouvel
engagement avec avec jean yves le drian
se sont mis d'accord pour dire que
l'union européenne vous savez on le dit
qu'elle progresse de crise en crise
c'était d'ailleurs la pensée de jean
monnet et en vérité c'est vrai elle a
fait une espèce de bon en avant quand
même on voit qu'elle met sur la table
une aide exceptionnelle alors 100
millions d'euros d'aidé humanitaire le
réfugié immédiate 500 millions d'euros
dette globale
effectivement la volonté de prendre des
millions de réfugiés en quelques jours
et 2 et de justement s'en occuper
dignement de
chercher à favoriser des corridors
humanitaires pour qu'il sorte du pays ce
que vladimir poutine ne souhaite pas des
mots quand même précautionneux de du
ministre français des affaires
étrangères parce qu on sait qu emmanuel
macron ne veut pas qu'on parle trop
fortement de vladimir poutine pour ne
pas risquer de rompre un dialogue qui
pour l'instant n'a pas abouti à beaucoup
de concessions de ce côté puisque les
couloirs humanitaires on l'a on l'a dit
avec cynisme vladimir poutine a
considéré qu'il ne pouvait se diriger
que vers la russie et la biélorussie
ce qui a de véritablement intéressant ce
qui ce qui frappe jean yves le drian
mais aussi tous ses homologues européens
puisqu'ils avaient tous les ministres du
développement sont compagnie les 27
c'est c'est une union européenne ni
rapide et audacieuse à la fois sur le
plan financier parce que souvent c'est
la diplomatie du portefeuille qui acquit
à qui a été préconisé mais sur le sur le
fond des sanctions aussi des sanctions
inégalée dans l'histoire de l'union
européenne parce que jusqu'à présent il
s'agissait de sanctions ciblées sur des
oligarques russes proche de vladimir
poutine on est passé quand même à
l'exclusion des banques russes du
système interbancaire swift ce qui est
du jamais vu ce qui provoque de graves
dommages d'ailleurs côté européen aussi
et puis là les européens ne sont pas
allés plus loin peut-être qu'on ne peut
pas aller plus loin sur le niveau des
sanctions on peut aller alors déjà dans
le système swift on n'a pas touché
encore toutes les banques parce que il y
avait des réticences franco-allemande et
c'est sûr sur des bancs soutenant de
grands groupes de grands groupes
européens mais mais mais c'est encore
possible et puis on voit bien qu'il ya
aussi de la marge de manoeuvre et de la
latitude par exemple présidentielle un
script qui parle lui de couper
complètement volontairement finalement
le pétrole russe et de refuser
finalement de s'approvisionner du côté
de la russie même si ça a un impact
évidemment alors que l'on n'est pas
encore sortie de l'hiver a effectivement
sur la flambée énergétique des prix des
prix de l'énergie en europe et ça on
peut encore aller dans cette direction
et puis il ya surtout la livraison et ça
c'est inédit aussi dans l'histoire de
l'union européenne un accord à
vingt-sept pour livrer des armes à un
pays pour qu'ils se défendent alors on
insiste sur le caractère défensif pour
qu'ils se défendent face à la russie et
puis il ya évidemment toute la question
aussi de la de la stratégie nucléaire
qui n'a pas été évoqué l'âme et la
france est désormais en europe la seule
puissance nucléaire puisque les
britanniques ont quitté le navire mais
mais mais n'empêche qu'on voit bien que
c'est l'union européenne qui est
vraiment aux premières loges au premier
plan de toutes les mesures finalement
qui frappe le plus durement les russes
puisque c'est sur son territoire de
l'union européenne que se déroule cette
guerre joseph bourrel caroline qui a
évoqué à plusieurs reprises un autre
pays la moldavie qui n'est pas dans
l'union européenne mais qui se trouve à
la frontière avec l'ukraine il a dit
elle se sent menacée il ya vraiment une
menace aujourd'hui oui dans ce contexte
nous allons augmenter la résille de la
moldavie et le soutien politique à la
moldavie donc soutien économique et
soutiens politiques effectivement avec
des régions des régions sécessionnistes
qui peut les athlètes en transnistrie ça
donc l'afrique de la moldavie je
t'achèterai pourrait être actionné par
moscou comme ça a été le cas du dombass
comme ça a été le cas des régions aussi
des régions géorgiennes séparatistes
qui pourrait être donc qui est sur le
chemin en quelque sorte et qui pourrait
être actionné donc beaucoup d'inquiétude
il y a trois république véritablement
qui était qui étaient tentés de se
rapprocher de l'union européenne et du
drapeau européen est tenté par une
adhésion au temps et qui d'ailleurs ont
signé des contrats d'association
économique avec l'union européenne s'est
véritablement alors l'ukraine en premier
lieu le plus gros d'entre plus gros pays
d'entre eux la géorgie et la moldavie
est aujourd'hui et bien les deux autres
sont sont dans cette incertitude cette
inquiétude cette possibilité à eux mêmes
d'être à nouveau en conflit ouvert avec
moscou ce qu'il ne souhaite pas et
l'union européenne qui envoie des
signaux halte là cette fois ci on ne
touche pas à ces territoires elles n'ont
pas été jusqu'à mentionner effectivement
l'entrée dans l'union européenne qui est
véritablement un bouclier on comprend
que c'est un bouclier qui est même aussi
fort que celui de l'otan finalement pour
certains pays regardez ce qui se passe
dans les trois républiques baltes
ancienne république soviétique
on voit bien qu'il ya quand même le
sentiment que c'est impossible cette
invasion alors qu'il ya de fortes
minorités russophones qui se serait
impossible que vladimir poutine avance
ses pions dans ses anciennes républiques
soviétiques tout simplement parce que l
en 2004 ont rejoint le club européen ont
rejoint l'union européenne et qu'il y a
désormais une protection il ya un
article dans les traités qui est bien
fait état de protection de défense
commune de tous pays membres qui
seraient attaqués parmi les 27 et donc
c'est vrai que cette union européenne et
bien elle fait envie maintenant essayer
c'est aussi pour ça qu'elle est d'un
certain point de vue rebooster elle dans
la campagne française aussi qui est en
cours effectivement l'union européenne
va être un sujet très important
merci beaucoup